police fired tear gas at demonstrators
in Caracas on Tuesday the demonstration
was organized by Venezuelan opposition
leader Hwang wydo wydo attempted to
negotiate with police who blocked
demonstrators from marching to Venezuela
x' National Assembly Building
mobilizations social action symbolic
acts of protest overwhelming protest
actions with everyone United today in
the fight for a free Venezuela this has
been as well as moment thousands
attended the demonstration in the
Venezuelan capital to protest against
worsening economic conditions in the
country well basically we want the whole
world to see what's happening in
Venezuela which is a very critical
situation without production without
food without medicines the country
totally paralyzed in all the country's
economic sectors at the United Nations
in Geneva the UN High Commissioner for
Human Rights Michelle Bachelet said the
situation in Venezuela has worsened in
recent months the ultimate police action
since my last update on the human rights
situation in Venezuela political
tensions and acts of violence by
security forces and government
supporters against opposition
parliamentarians have continued a
separate rally was convened in downtown
Caracas in support of Venezuelan
president Nicolas Maduro the latest
political tensions in the South American
nations stem from a growing violence
against members of Venezuela's political
opposition including the arrest of
several parliament members according to
the latest updates from the UN some four
point nine million people have fled
Venezuela as a result of the crisis when
real Rapallo al Jazeera